for years the landlock country of
Ethiopia has wanted access to a sea port
its prime minister is now risking War to
try to get one Ethiopia is here in the
Horn of Africa a region riddled with
Civil War armed disputes in the Red Sea
and even Pirates it's one of the most
conflict scarred parts of the world and
a new dispute is brewing over a stretch
of land here by Bara Port near the mouth
of the Red Sea it's in Somali land a
territory which claims indep dependence
from Somalia it has been on a 30-year
quest to get International recognition
as an independent state on January 1st
somal land signed a deal with Ethiopia
giving it access to the port and land
for a naval base but that comes at a
[Music]
price to Somalia this is a clear
violation of its
sovereignty as with many African border
disputes problems here began in the
colonial era when European powers carved
up the continent what are now Somalia
and Eritrea were Italian colonies while
Britain occupied Somali land the British
pushed out the Italians during the
second world war but by the 1960s all
the countries had gained independence
Somali land unified with Somalia and the
Ethiopian Empire annexed Eritrea but the
borders changed again in the
1990s after a brutal Civil War tra
gained independence leaving Ethiopia
landlocked once again and Somali land
broke away from
Somalia since then Somali land's pleas
for recognition have been ignored but it
has become a functioning state in Albert
name for Ethiopia recognizing Somali
land's sovereignty would seem a small
price to pay for its decades long search
for sea access especially as Ethiopia
has considered another option the port
of assab in erria but that would mean
another horrific War between the two
countries actually taking control of a
part of Somali land would be a risky
move too Somalia is unlikely to give it
away without putting up a
fight